[Musique]
m
bonsoir bonsoir à tous ceux qui sont
restés tardivement écoute pour nous
bonsoir pour ce premier post scriptum
puisque c'est pour nous et je l'espère
pour vous aussi une grande première
pierre la thèse je crois qu'il faut que
nous expliquions un petit peu ce que
sera post scriptum une émission qui sera
en direct dans ce petit café littéraire
que nous avons reconstitué ce soir tous
les mercredis que tous ceux qui aiment
les livres pouvons venir en parler avec
nous et nous disons bien tout ce parce
que si en ce moment vous êtes en train
de vous dire j'aimerais bien parler de
tels livres que j'ai trouvé excellent
mais je ne sais pas comment le faire et
bien vous écrivez un post scriptum 116
avenue du président-kennedy paris 16e et
si votre lait c'est tout de même un
pouce au clair car il ne suffit pas nous
dire j'aimerais bien vous parlez de tels
niveaux nous y voilà pourquoi je laime
pourquoi je le déteste car vous pouvez
aussi venir nous dire que vous détestez
un livre eh bien vous aurez une chance
de venir même de province car nous vous
offrirons le voyage très généreusement
pour venir un soir avec nous je crois
que ça c'est très important parce que le
le but cette émission son rôle c'est
d'être une émission critique une mission
critique c'est à dire que dans cette
énorme actualité littéraire et surtout
en ce moment nous avons demandé à
certaines personnes à des critiques
professionnels ou à des gens qui
n'étaient pas des critiques
professionnels de venir nous parler d'un
livre qu'ils aimaient ou même d'un livre
qui détestait et il y aura le challenger
il y aura des gens qui aimeront des gens
qui ne m'ont pas et ça va être le cas ce
soir comme cette actrice ou bien vous
dire que tout le monde peut parler d'un
livre et même souvent un auteur que nous
dire mais vous savez c'est ma grand mère
qui la mettait la meilleure lectrice de
mon livre ou même c'est ma concierge ou
montmain boulangère et je crois que
souvent nous avons de bonnes surprises
comme ça qu'il ya beaucoup d'auteurs qui
nous disent j'ai reçu une lettre
merveilleuse de francs 20 d'un monsieur
qui a très bien compris mon livre et
bien voilà une occasion de venir réparer
parfois une injustice comme ça que les
libraires les éditeurs les directeurs de
collection littéraire pourront amener
leur poulain pourront dire le livre de
la semaine qu'ils ont préféré c'est à
cette actualité est bibliothécaire mini
cible on peut venir aussi non leur
signalant que nous les accueillerons
volontiers
alors je pense qu'il faut peut-être dire
que ce soir nous avons parmi nous une
brillante assembler je crois qu'on peut
les citer et vous aurez françois
truffaut lucien bodard michel cournot
la viéle ski patricia finaly pierre
bourgeade jacqueline bard dominique de
roux il y à là quelques attaché de
presse de maison d'édition que vous
présenteront au passage beaucoup
d'autres amis qui sont l'ajout en
oublier quelques-uns d'ailleurs et
jean-claude silbertanne qui est à côté
de nous pour nous parler de quelques
lives et d'un roman policier virginie
servir à chacun à voir vous pouvez
d'ailleurs déjà les leur offrir voir
virginie j'espère que s'ils ont dû ils
seront plus prolixe est plus bavard
et puis on pourrait peut-être maintenant
commencer nous avons aussi un journal
qui inquiète qui vient de sortir qui
sort demain matin voilà vous en aurez la
primeur sur un téléspectateur ce soir
c'est actuelle qui est un journal de
l'underground et actuel c'est son
premier numéro c'est patrick rambaud
cayla soir qui nous a amené les
critiques littéraires d'actuels
souterrain si vous préférez pour le
parti leur graal c'est super ça bon je
pense qu'on pourrait tout sur commencer
par le premier les livres de cette
soirée et c'est un livre qui est paru
aujourd'hui le wall of sound for me
chercher eh bien le voilà c'est le
ghetto le ghetto un titre assez bizarre
d'aller dire le ghetto c'est de patricia
finaly patricia finaly nous nous la
connaissons très bien comment vous la
présentera pas puisque ici les auteurs
n'ont pas tellement la parole ce sont
ceux qui aiment les livres et les
auteurs n'ont pas forcément leur propre
liste d'ailleurs nous dira tout à
l'heure voilà pas de sa finale et vous
la voyez là comme ça qui vous la verrez
en réalité aussi
c'est chez gallimard et c'est lucien
bodard qui va nous dire pourquoi il est
là choisi ce livre est pourquoi ils
l'aiment
oui c'est parce qu ils nous détestent en
11e viande non non ce temps les livres
eux courageux le quartier cabano
parce que patricia au final il est connu
voyez ce diablotin rouge là bas j'ai
connu deux soirées mondaines chez les
gens elle tenait des discours et tout le
monde se tordait parce que c'est
absolument marrant à l'instance de
l'épithète du vocabulaire de l'adverbe
la grossièreté qui est absolument
fantastique et elle démolit tout le
monde en même temps
et puis mais à l'époque du boucau vous
n'aviez pas l'air d'avoir beaucoup
d'amis
d'après ce que vous décrivez et pourtant
le sujet de prêter triste profondément
triste c'est l'enfant l'enfant une
fillette juive allemande
la france occupe est menacé par tous les
dangers avec son père disparu en
allemagne dans les camps de
concentration et probablement dans les
fours crématoires avec autour d'elle une
famille lointaine qui apparaît au qui
disparaît et cuillères de kankan
d'institutions en institution toujours
menacés à chaque instant d'être raf est
déporté alors fi nally au fond se
défendre contre ça à la rigolade
elle veut rien prendre au sérieux elle
rien contre auxerre 1-1 au sacré elle
veut croire en rien et alors un loup
décrit comme dans un film de charlot
selon sal que l'admirent elle à son
échelle c'est un petit charlot elle
décrit la succession de ses aventures
elle est en mains de toutes sortes de
gens bien intentionnés le plus ou moins
mais les vandales par une opa de
tendresse profonde ne dis pas que le
recherchent d'ailleurs posco toit de la
halle à sa couleur sa pudeur c'est la
provocation c'est la blague c'est le cas
c'est la cabane c'est de croire qu
choses profondément immédiate et
matérielles par exemple la bouffe et
l'argent et l'or de terminale j'espère
que vous me rapportez menacée mais c'est
pour après parce qu'on n'a jamais gagné
de sa vie là qui s'enfuit
je ne sais pas l'argent c'est un
prétexte pour démolir cabaret c'est la
cavale c'est son plaisir
alors vous d asie il ya un côté azimi
mais plus profond parce que quand même
c'est une fillette avait désespéré il
faut se rappeler quand même sa situation
mais ça elle n'en parle jamais ça de
loin en loin on s'aperçoit par une ligne
qui effectivement dans l'école où qu'en
bd on a ramassé sainte non de gauche lui
qui dès qu'ils partent gagnant n'est pas
parce que c'est une allemande qui est
polonaise qui est français on ne sait
pas elle n'a pas d'appuyer aérien elle
s'en tire d'ailleurs la préoccupation 16
de ses papiers des papiers d'identité la
marque encore maintenant cet extrait de
cette en avoir est ce que vous
alors oubliez toutes ses aventures elle
décrit le monde que le traversent ce le
monde et directeurs d'institutions le
monde des bonnes soeurs le banque des
paysans parce que depuis plus de
l'assistance publique
alors là pour sentir les défauts des
gens et les faiblesses des gens en verve
et un talent absolument extraordinaire
et particulièrement il ya un portrait de
monsieur sifflets qui est la chaîne me
siffler c'est rouge du bateleur et
peseux sifflet y ait tout le monde
encore plus qu'ali le déteste le monde
entier hors et le tristement radical si
vous voulez rouge parce qu'il n'aime pas
le radical mais alors elle ils
s'entendent d'abord bien à condition
comme on l'appelle net parce que
monsieur si je les écris ça peut
s'appliquer naître et ensuite le ccif
exige qu'on travaille alors elle
finalisé plus d'accord parce qu'elle
veut pas travailler travailler
elle met son art à ne pas travailler et
alors le bouquin se poursuit elle
n'épargne personne
pour la première partie elle a plutôt
affaire à des gens qu alors ce sont les
gens bons petits trinquent
dans la seconde partie là plutôt affaire
à des gens riches il ya des juifs parce
que toutes ces oeuvres sont plus ou
moins patronné par des organisations et
ce rallye puisque rennes et israël est
elle-même pendant la première partie se
soit pas trop parce que c'est ouattara
hier à l'interférence des méchins dans
la seconde partie elle est directement
liée aux grandes organisations
l'israélite mais l'organisation est
rallye c'est quelque chose de supérieur
il admis c'est un casque et la bio mines
ça ne casse les pieds
donc les démolit successivement les uns
après les autres
il ya une sorte de petite vengeance
personnelle qui couvait depuis très
longtemps
et moi je me suis presque étonné qu'elle
est couvé pendant si longtemps c'est à
dire non c'est pas vraiment mon jour
c'est à dire que sais-je les gens que je
voyais je parle de la deuxième partie de
ces fameux rupins chez qui je faisais
les pauvres le samedi c'était des gens
dont j'avais rien à [ __ ] finalement
j'y allais pour le cinéma enfin je
racontais que j'aimais la peinture en
espérant tout ça c'est pas une bombe
dans ce jeu les raconter dans des
bistrots à des gens je les raconte jean
luc godard avec qui j'ai travaillé je
les raconte à jacques rivette à des tas
de gens et qui m'ont dit au fond tu
devrais l'écrire et puis je me suis dit
voilà s'il ya un moyen de gagner du fric
à vos services
quel effet ça fait un premier roman
publié puisqu'on n'a pas dit mais c'est
un premier roman qui sort aujourd'hui
le fait de le voir tout ball à la
couverture brillante vertes et rouges
comme ça je sais pas j'ai assisté
tellement des premières de gens de
cinéma que j'ai l'impression que c'est
le film un livre de godard par exemple
ça me fait exactement le même effet je
suis ému pareil que tant que je vais la
première fois un film comme ça andré la
barre vous l'avez lu ce livre de patrice
hier ben je vais je peux dire que je les
ai vus écrire dix pages par dix pages ça
mais combien de temps premier cité par
à-coups ça veut dire que pendant un
certain temps
elle écrivait dix pages tous les jours
10 12 pages et puis il y avait des
moments où ça n'allait pas très bien
elle s'est arrêtée pendant 2 3 mois du
elle partira campagne il a réécrit puis
l arrêter c'est à dire tantôt elle
croyait tantôt les croyez pas je crois
que c'est ça son tour et puis finalement
je crois qu'elle est trop tard même
maintenant c'est bien de ne pas croire
trop un livre parce que elle démystifie
un peu la littérature aussi un trait
façon c'est quoi c'est trop compliqué
pour moi je suis pas un intellectuel
pour nourrir
pourquoi s'y voit ce qu'il ya aussi une
petite pas une petite griffe à l'éditeur
aussi un moment donné on va demander à
truffaut ce qu'il a dit là il a lui déjà
non mais oui c'est probablement le seul
livre que j'ai lu parmi ceux dont vous
allez parler ouais moi je les trouvais
super magnifique j'ai regretté qu'il ne
soit pas plus gros plus épais plus
londres parce que in et ils ressemblent
à des gros livres en rayon tenir sans
blague
il ressemble à la première partie d'un
livre qu'il serait beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus important et lorsqu on
peut penser c'est qu'elle a un tel style
patricia qu'on aimerait que livrent les
plus d'ambition maintenant oui puis
parce que cela l'histoire se déroule sur
une grande sur une durée importante
aussi et on aimerait entrer dans les
détails justement je pense que lucien
bodard l'épisode sifflets de noix le à
celui qui ne l'est plus grands souvenirs
et j'aurais voulu que tout le livre soit
soit comme ça mais enfin je crois qu'on
aura la suite enfants devraient
normalement avoir huit pour la promo
presse ghetto patricia finaly je suis un
peu rapide aujourd'hui nous allons être
un peu rapide parce que comme c'est la
première émission il ya tellement de
livres on en a mis partout sur les
tables on n'aura pas le temps de parler
de tout vous avez fait une petite
préface pour un livre qui paraît chez
albin michel un flic sur la vague qui
s'appelle testament d'un camp de bernard
gher pense à tout ça est un premier
roman
oui c'est ça mais très différent oui
c'est celui là je ne sais pas je veux
pas jouer le critique littéraire mois et
donc si celui de patricia d'école
célibat et aussi de l'école cocteau
ouais c'est un livre je suppose écrit un
peu en admiration sinon en hommage à
cocteau radiguet voilà c'est ça c'est
tout à fait ça je les ai reçus sous
forme de scénario ou même d'un début de
scénario et
il m'a semblé plus littéraires
cinématographiques je sais pas enfin
toujours est il que j'ai écrit à bernard
coeur je n'ai jamais rencontré parce
qu'ils habitent liège je lui écris c'est
peut-être pas un film vous devriez
peut-être continuer sous cette sous une
forme de roman puisque c'était écrit
comme un premier chapitre de roman
et puis quelques mois plus tard il m'a
fait la surprise de m'envoyer le jeu de
preuves en disant qu'il avait là qu'il
était édité chez albin michel
j'ai écrit quelques mots comme ça enfin
quelques quelques petits mots qu'on me
raconter un peu l'histoire la façon dont
ce manuscrit était arrivé sans aucune
sans aucune prétention évidemment à
déborder ce produit cru littéraire parce
que je ne sais pas ce qu'on pensera du
lait moi je trouve touchant les sincères
et bien oui c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment une première oeuvre
c'est amérique vient de parler d'une
collection qui s'appelle la vague est
consacrée aux jeunes auteurs s'étaient
encore peut-être pas tout à fait aboutie
mais il ya une promesse en tout cas
c'est à dire c'est difficilement oui ça
peut pas être abouti parce que c'est en
cet ambitieux
c'est ambitieux aussi dans l'écriture
voilà ce n'est pas ce n'est pas écrit
absolument comme il pense il ya une il
ya un grand désir de l'élégance d'un an
et voilà et quelquefois peut-être penser
qu'ils voulaient envoyer en pensant à
antoine doinel parce que c'est un
personnage des 400 coups je suppose
puisque tout ça devait se passer il ya
deux ans à peu près oui je suppose que
c'est un peu plus tôt référence même
peut-être abusé voyez que les garçons
que je ne sais pas ce sera peut-être en
référence à dwan et je me souviens pas à
tout ça nous amène bien sûr aussi à une
publication qui nous a surpris parce que
françois truffaut de proposer jusqu'à
présent finalement des entretiens avec
hitchcock et là c'est une oeuvre
d'auteur que vous nous proposez
mais à mi-chemin peut-être de la
véritable oeuvre d'auteur on aura
peut-être un jour
non c'est pas une oeuvre d'auteur ce pas
un livre de littérature d'un livre c'est
un lit vous savez c'est un peu
particulier en france mais on le fait
beaucoup en amérique
quoique on l'a fait en france pour les
films d'ingmar bergman ça consiste à
réunir les scénarios de plusieurs films
en y adjoignant quelquefois le premier
traitement ou les notes de construction
qui donne une idée voilà sur la façon
dont les choses se sont faites alors il
s'agit des aventures
bonnel ferme ça que se livrent à trois
sous titre les 400 coups baisers volés
domicile conjugal on n'a pas dit non
plus c'était au mercure de france
le petit général les aventures dans un
autre vol doit elle est ce que vous
considérez ça au fond comme un roman est
ce qu'on voit à lire ça comme un robot
non non non absolument pas non non non
non c'est un c'est un document disons
que les films aujourd'hui comporte une
marche d'improvisation plus grande qu
autrefois je pense qu'on aurait pu
éviter les scénarios de prévert quelques
ailes je pense qu'ils subissent très peu
de modifications le scénario des enfants
du paradis par exemple doit être
semblable aux films terminés aujourd'hui
les films subissent beaucoup de
modifications au tournage et puis au
montage
le film finit on n'a jamais d'état
littéraire du fil alors ce scénario en
réalité sont reconstitués après coup sur
la table de montage en regardant le film
et puis voilà je ne pense pas que ce
soit il s'agit pas du tout d'un genre
littéraire c'est un document ça peut
servir d'outil de travail s'ils
voulaient à des étudiants des gens qui
font des tests des gens qui cherchent
font des recherches sur l'élaboration de
scénarios voilà il ya quelque chose qui
m'a beaucoup frappé l'irlande dans les
skis ce de scénarios de l'amour à vingt
ans et je dois dire que j'ai manqué
l'amour à vingt ans le film à sketch
dans lequel vous aviez faire des sketchs
et j'ai lu donc ce texte et j'ai trouvé
extraordinaire les skis ce qui fait
quatre pages et je trouve que là
vraiment on ce qu'on regrette presque
truffaut n'ai pas le temps de faire un
recueil de nouvelles publié un roman
parce que je trouve ça absolument
merveilleux en quatre pages on a
l'équivalent d'une petite nouvelle de
fitzgerald par exemple oui et le film
enfin il n'était pas très difficile à
faire c'est un film de 25 minutes mais a
été fait vraiment à partir de ces quatre
pages là il n'y avait rien d'autre
enfin le dialogue était improvisé donc
au jour le jour mais
enfin c'est vrai j'ai pensé déjà ça
peut-être à l'idée d'un recueil de
nouvelles comme ça sur des choses
anciennes mais je crois que vous devriez
le faire parce que là vraiment il ya un
style il ya quelque chose qui va très
vite cette histoire de ce garçon qui
tombe amoureux de cette fille qui finit
par être invité par les parents je viens
ami de la famille et finalement un soir
elle 120 avec un comme ça avec un flirt
et lui reste avec les parents c'est un
raccourci merveilleux d'une histoire
d'amour pendant le truffaut comment
est-ce que le le cinéaste considère le
roman parce que le roman va être au
moins dans les premières semaines de
l'émission notre sujet principal c'est
la saison du rendement est ce que le
cinéaste n'a pas une sorte de plus pas
de mépris mais de désintérêt envers le
genre du roman
justement parce que vous avez choisi
leur exprimer plus tôt par le film non
non pas du tout moi j'ai toujours aimé
les romans j'ai toujours eu beaucoup de
mal à lire autre chose que des romans
seulement je commence seulement
maintenant à m'intéresser aux choses
vraies aux mémoires souvenirs choses
comme ça mais sinon je n'aimais que la
fiction j'ai toujours aimé les romans
parce que c'était effectivement ce qui
était plus proche d'un film et vous êtes
un grand découvreur brevans parce que
j'aime les films qui ressemblent à des
romans enfin les films que j'aime le
plus chez trois sont les films qui
comporte une grande part de commentaires
par exemple j'aime beaucoup entendre de
la littérature au cinéma en même temps
envoyé contre les romains en tout cas
françois truffaut nous vous disons ce
que nous disons à tout ce que nous
invitons ici
lorsqu'il ya un livre que vous aimez
beaucoup vous venez un soir ici à
mercredi vous venez avec nous et vous
venez nous dire je viens dire un livre
j'aime beaucoup comme ça dernier moment
vous pouvez toujours venir vous serez
bien accueillis dans cette émission les
six d'ailleurs vous avez vu une critique
qui vous a parfaitement énervé par ce
contrat était tombé sur le livret que ça
aurait pas plu du tout vous êtes
également le bienvenu puisque c'est
aussi le rôle de cette émission pendant
que nous y sommes la piste ya beaucoup
de livres sur les tables on est tous
même dire ce qu'il y a il ya par exemple
une nouvelle collection que plus dit
pierrot ray qui s'appelle en verve et ce
sont des mots proposés aphorismes choisi
de certains écrivains non j'ai choisi à
son chalet et paul léautaud cantilien
vian si bien vian et un canot
moi j'aime bien de valfrance allen paul
léautaud ils sont assez rigolo oui c'est
sûr le alphonse allais évidemment c'est
très facile mais enfin on on s'amuse
bien quand on lit un extrait de 2 plus 2
moi je suis un type dans le genre de
napoléon 1er ma femme s'appelle
joséphine et l'autre est pour moi je
suis un type dans le genre de molière je
suis co q c'est facile vous me direz
mais en face et de la force à l'amusant
alors il ya notre collection qui vient
de paraître chez laffont connaissent
parce que la sexualité rapport à il a
connaissance de sexualité nouvelle
collection chez laffont et je peux pas
m'empêcher de vous je veux pas vous
citer ce très très respectable une
collection choix qu'il faut vraiment
donner des informations sur les maladies
vénériennes les hormones sexuelles etc
on apprend des choses très intéressantes
d'ailleurs la comparaison un disparition
des maladies vénériennes entre la
disparition du clergé bon ça aussi on
pourra en parler mais n'en parle pas on
dort mais il ya une chose très être
assez amusant de l'humanité n'est rien
c'est traduit de l'anglais tout ça et
avant-dernière nous parle des symptômes
d'une maladie je ne sais plus laquelle
d'ailleurs et on nous dit qu'il ya pas
réunies si une certaine grosseur de la
taille d'une balle de cricket français
sont un peu affolée mais on s'en doute
jamais vu de partie de cricket en fait
le tout même collection que mais
signalons que nous sommes la sexualité
si on vous parlera de michel déon la
prochaine fois c'est michel tournier qui
veut nous parler des poneys sauvages y
en ad'autres on vous en signalera et
maintenant on pourrait en venir un autre
nos deux autres invités qui relatait stu
pour être tourné vers qui me tourner
vers eux illégalement ce livre en main
c'est rossi un premier roman ne faisons
pas encore exprès ça vient d'être publié
chez robert laffont s'appelle voronej et
l'auteur en lna bienne ce qui est alors
comme il s'agissait c'était le
jeu de l'émission connaît la de ce
qu'ils trouvent un supporters elle a
trouvé sans aller fort loin elle a
trouvé la présence de son cinéaste
critique et maric et michel cournot et
c'est lui qui va donc parler du roman de
sa femme de ce voronej donné la belgique
chez robert laffont
je vais vous dire d'abord que si vous
connaissiez le caractère de bella et sa
nature
les mots de marie et de femmes ne
convient absolument encore tout ce qui
est conjugale 17h le c'est d'ailleurs
une des choses qui m'a indiqué qu'elle
était en train d'écrire le livre parce
que la maison elle y est presque jamais
le disparaît des semaines des mois ou
alors quand est lié il ya 300 personnes
des soudanais des russes qui sont là de
passage et l'année dernière elle était
la maison qui est je me demandais ce
qu'elle y faisait tout simplement que
c'était l'endroit le plus tranquille
quand même cour alors quel est ce qu'il
pourrait peut-être sans raconter
l'histoire parce qu'on va pas on ira par
gauthier histoire d'autant plus que
l'histoire est racontée par un par un
homme qui est français quel journaliste
tout ça est un peu curieux et qui ne
casse rien le
lui-même donc le nom ce qu'il ya c'est
que ce mois j'ai été naturellement très
sensible à sif parce que vous comprenez
c'est tout ce que je trouve beau
littérature ça arrive aux lecteurs c'est
pas de la lecture
le papier le caractère disparaissent
complètement y compris l'acte e mental
de ligne c'est une suite de surprise
c'est un livre qui fait des surprises
aux lecteurs qui lui fait de sorte de
cadeau
les émotions d'une façon très simple
sans prétention apparente c'est du roman
de gare vraiment si l'on veut comme on
le faisait dans les années 30 mais c'est
de la poésie et je crois vraiment très
belle parce que très sain c'est vraiment
le livre d'émotion merveilleux qui en
plus raconte des choses extrêmement
graves
en fait puisque cette histoire d'amour
se fasse
au moment où la terreur commence à
monter sous staline mais vous michel
cours d'eau et en vous même écrivain et
souvenez peut-être contraction de dire
ah ben moi je peux pas la france comme
ça je corrigerai si je râle 13 le ce qui
m'est arrivé j'ai été jaloux de certains
personnages alors que c'est pas tout à
fait mon caractère
il y en avait que je trouvais trop bien
les garçons et que je me demandais d'où
il sortait les la vieille ce qui suit
et puis c'est un personnage qui existe
dans le livre on le voit un moment donné
mais c'est devenu vraiment un fantôme je
considère que je le rate est totalement
mais c'est à cause de lui
est ce que je me suis entraîné à faire
un personnage de mire est vraiment un
homme extraordinaire anglo saxons
évidemment et voilà il devait arriver un
jour j alors que personne ne l'attendait
ce que monsieur trop bizarre qu'il
connaissait des landes
deux langues que par exemple ne parlait
vraiment tout 200 personnes au monde et
avec tout ça il était du leader pour du
juge
alors tout ça mais d'une telle leader
que c'est absolument vrai j'étais sûr
que quand il sortait dans les rues de
port dvi d'amendé des enfants doivent
courir derrière lui écrit et je voulais
faire de cela un personnage tout cela
c'est tout ce que je vous disais ça
existe dans le livre c'est complètement
raté et pour une raison que je donnais à
partir d'un certain moment je commençais
lui donnait justement à mon passage en
géorgie c'est le moment où je le donnais
un livre une chaîne et quand il a lu
qu'il existe à tout le moins possible
des marques et des véritables scènes
absolument dément des andouilles vie s
alors que vraiment cette équipe
complètement inventé comme tous les
personnages de mon livre vraiment vous
ne vous en faites de toutes pièces
l'espèce de tout simplement parce que le
tour et littérairement je me suis dit
j'ai raté j'ai raté je me suis mis à l'
fait miauler je me mis à lui donner de
petites erreurs comme ça correct si on
voulait enfin et je le rate complètement
avorté il existe mais comme ça de
passage mais dites moi le le fait que
l'histoire soit disant la journaliste
rentrée qui fait connaissance d'une
russe pendant un voyage en 1900
génétique
il ya quand même un parallèle qu'on peut
faire avec le mariage michel cournot les
lavier qui vous êtes quand même connu la
même façon non il n'y a aucun rapport à
ses livres une et ankara pour nous un
peu moins michel paul il est dit à juste
titre est fait
j'aime beaucoup ses démons pôle mer
c'est pas du tout michel et c'est pas du
tout depuis lors le public est ce que
quelqu'un a lu le livre déjà voronej ici
je compte louis bardo 6 mars il ya deux
lecteurs jacqueline bard d'abord voir
moi j'aime beaucoup ça mais je suis
humaine monde comme je tenais les lie
je me demande si je ne le vois pas à
travers m c'est ça je suis très bon déjà
je peux je je ne peux pas être bon juge
ouais pour moi c'est une est là qui
raconte une histoire alors évidemment on
la voit très bien on la voit très bien
dans les années 30 en train de traîner
les châles de diana et de cette vertu
sur son passé à chasser ces normes nous
avons demandé un critique la foire votre
pictural le lire un livre
et c'était 097 olivier nanteau qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de livres de dan
hamhuis qui est bien ya plusieurs choses
d'abord je suis contente michel gondry
et annick sans prétention que je crois
qu'il faut surtout c'est vraiment un
livre très léger ce qui régit d'où
sortent quelques images quelques
personnages comme ça qui sont assez bien
fins détails et mais c'est un livre très
rapide enfin qu'on survole très
rapidement on a quelques images du monde
et puis ont ensuite moi je voudrais dire
justement à propos de l'assimilation on
peut faire des deux personnages du livre
michel cournot nla bielski que moi je ne
les connais l'un et l'autre que par ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est à dire cournot
comme critique de cinéma comme cinéaste
nla bielski que j'ai vu dans le film de
michel cournot les gauloises bleues et
on a assez l'impression quand même que
les deux personnages l'homme et la femme
se greffe sur ce que représente aux yeux
du d'un certain public l'image
cournot nla bielski faisant pour cournot
les critiques qu'il fait jouant pour
nella bielski comme elle joue on a assez
tendance à les replacer la source même
si c'est pas vrai c'est l'idée qui vient
à l'esprit
quels sont pour vous les gens qui ne
m'ont pas sony a vraiment un arménien
pourquoi les messages je vois pas
peut-être de type complètement intoxiqué
par le mental tel quel les gags tel quel
mais pas plus
on lui demandera je crois qu'après
burnett et la pièce qui nous ont passé
quelques clips sur cette table nous
avons un énorme au bouquin c'est le jean
pierre chabrol qui paie son petit lot
le canot fraternité où ça peut même plus
d'un kilo nettement mais plus nous en
parlerons dans quinze jours à l'occasion
d'une émission sur la commune canon
fraternité dont cécile saint laurent
sera aussi a déjà vidé puisqu'il allie
les clés la commune à la commune art il
ya une collection tarzan dont on parlera
je crois que sylvie vartan et johnny
hallyday pour tout ça le petit colonel
de jacques florent jean-luc surpuissant
poche claudel paul morand monte au ciel
boris vian les fourmis qu'ils
s'ennuyaient qui a publié le théâtre et
combat le critique de théâtre genre ivan
des pèlerines et puis maintenant on
reste tourné vers un de quoi notre table
une table très fournie d'ailleurs oui là
on va parler d'un autre livre un autre
genre de livre avec jacqueline bard j'ai
pas dit tout à l'heure vous étiez
critique de l est que vous étiez aussi
critiques de plusieurs journaux
professionnels pour les uns bref une
vraie influence considérable d'ailleurs
je suis si le train est très réputé très
pour la très peur de bougeoirs howie je
fais ce que je fais il ya des attachés
de presse de transition derrière puis à
13h30
la mayo le délateur c les éditions
flammarion maillot qui me tournait le
dos et d'édition et de la rose alors
autour de cette table de varla de
bistrots sont bien bu ça va vous avez
encore soit on va parler maintenant d'un
autre livre que je vais vous montrer
c'est la guerre de jmg jean marie
gustave le clézio je vous le mets nous
montre comme ça voilà la guerre
collection le chemin gallimard vous le
voyez comme ça c'est le sixième livre de
croix de la légion qui a eu lieu en 1964
le prix renaudot pour le procès verbal
voilà moi c'est un livre que je j'adore
énormément mais je crois que beaucoup de
gens qui le détestent et alors comme le
clézio est un écrivain part considéré
par certains comme difficile on va
peut-être essayer d'expliciter un peu ce
problème alors je leur ai alors demandé
avant deux étudiants qui l'ont lu eux
comment vous appelez-vous jean marc
ghanassia bon et francis à faire mieux
vous l'avez lu tous les deux et viennent
pas tout à fait du même avis qu'en
pensez vous non versement effectivement
il ya beaucoup de choses que j'aime dans
ce livre parce que bon dès la lecture
ce livre m'a fait vraiment un choc très
important parce que j'y ai retrouvé un
petit peu tout les tous les fantasmes
toutes les obsessions qu'on peut
retrouver lorsque l'on se promène
lorsqu'on marche dans la rue encore en
dedans des immeubles lorsque l'on va
faire le marché dans un supermarché ou
comme ça et j'étais extrêmement
impressionné par ce livre parce
qu'effectivement à certains moments on
se retrouve un peu dans la situation de
l'héroïne qui est de rechercher son
identité à travers les signes qui sont
divulgués rechercher son identité son
bref son existence son insertion dans
l'assaut dans une certaine forme de
société qui nous a été balancée comme ça
après la guerre et dans laquelle on
arrive dans un cas on est complètement
étranger où on essaye quand même de
trouver quelque chose qui nous ressemble
des signaux naturels des signes qui
n'ont pas été subvertit est monopolisé
par certains mais c'est un livre en fête
qui débouche sur une espèce de
destruction volonté de destruction
totale parce que aucun signe ou du moins
ils sont trop faibles ne peuvent nous
satisfaire ne peut nous aider à nous
reconnaître essentiellement dans cette
société qui ne va être qui a été
construite sans nous qui a été
construite non pas pour nous mais
presque contre nous et bon enfin ça nous
amène à l'anarchie ou à la boit la mort
enfin oui mais vous avez l'air de dire
qui a été construite on ne sait pas par
qui en réalité au fond on a l'impression
de voir le plaisir qu'elle a été
construit par une espèce de nature par
un inconscient à la fois dedans à
l'intérieur de l'homme et de la nature
qui fait cette espèce de construction
c'est ça non pas vraiment en fait ils
parlent souvent de rechercher les plans
qu'un des murs j'aurais fait c'est à
dire que il dit souvent effectivement
quelle sur les plans du monde de fond
qui s'est amusé à faire ce monde
sera-t-il s'arrêtera saint flour enfin
ça qu'il recherche sont et il arrive un
moment donné où il parle de trois mythes
dont le mythe du monopole qui est
extrêmement important je crois parce
qu'après cela il ya une cassure
comme si c'était effectivement un des
murs qui avait organisé ce monde comme
une forme de folie et de violence entre
chaque être dans chaque situation est
que l'héroïne ne peut pas comprendre et
ne veut pas comprendre parce que si elle
ne comprenait ce serait sa propre mort
et contre cela ne peut rien faire alors
je crois que justement que ce livre est
un peu suicidaire parce qu'il nous offre
deux solutions soit la mort de la
société soit sa propre mort soit
détruire tous totalement comme il le dit
à la fin du livre en rêvant c'est-à-dire
tout brûler tout cas c'est parce que il
n'ya pas notre place et parce qu'elle a
été fait sans nous et contre nous soit
bon alors la révolte du rhône ou parce
qu'ils pillent enfin c'est une sorte de
mort quoi martyrs et puis tous les ce et
on est bon alors ça m'a donné un choc
mais je crois que cette forme d' analyse
de la société nous pousse plus ou moins
nous montre là que parce que d'abord on
revient toujours au point de départ
parce que dès le départ béatrice et
qu'elle ne sera jamais comment
s'identifier
le trouvèrent jamais les signes il le
dit dès le début et ça vous a soit pas
abordée déjà un masque plutôt négative
de votre critique et je crois que les
plus tôt cet aspect là que vous voulez
souligné j'aimerais souligner deux
choses d'abord que l'écriture
enfin du point de vie l'écriture pur je
trouve ça assez faible en face une
écriture neutre
tu fais que décrire l'écrire l'objet du
monde
écrire des signes tandis qu'elle n'écrit
pas elle-même une écriture un peu de la
nullité et puis du point de vue des
idées bien ma foi il n'y a pas grand
chose de nouveau depuis depuis les
autres livres
à part peut-être une espèce de un
recensement du monde on dirait qu'il est
partout qu'il est allé avec un carnet et
avec un papier dans tous les lièvres et
puis il a écrit sur un carnet il a écrit
les boîtes de conserves il a écrit les
tubulures de voiture il a écrit tout ce
qu'il a vu et puis ça ne débouche sur
rien ils auront fini le livre on est
déçus parce qu'on se demande où ils vont
venir
alors qu'est ce qu'il veut faire avec
sully on sait pas c'est un livre
poétique moi je crois que c'est une
gigantesque allégorie parce que la seule
chose qui qui semblera intéressante si
le rêve enfin espèces d'allégories
qu'elle fait bab je parle de l'héroïne
de la guerre entre parenthèses la guerre
c'est c'est la lutte en face et c'est le
monde dans son agressivité et sa
violence c'est chacun fait chacun valant
exprimé son rapport à une individualité
qui est celle de 2,2 le clézio symbolise
très très narcissique d'améliorer ça
vous ne trouvez pas au point de
l'écriture je te vois que des écrivains
américains comme jan bos ont été
beaucoup plus loin dans ce sens de le
clézio les avants le clézio ham seule
une antho veut intervenir
oui parce qu'on a on a souvent enfin
retrouvé chez le clézio une certaine
similitude avec les peintres du pop
américain et il ya peut-être quelque
chose de ça dans cette manière de
montrer brut des produits de
civilisation et puis de les montrer et
c'est tout vous allez montrer dans un
contexte différent de celui qui est là
jacqueline bard de vous ben écoutez ça
sans grande passion parce que je crois
que le clézio ne vous touche pas tant
fonde emmanuel dunand pas pour moi c'est
l'autre les yeux c'est le designer
littérature ces quelques journées les
parisiens
j'apprécie j'apprécie je mets juste le
faire mais je trouve que le clézio vous
voyez c'est quelque chose
il ressemble à ces livres et les livres
lus ressort c'est quelque chose de très
beau podium qu'on peut en faire et c'est
presque un produit de luxe présent
sceptique on voit très bien sous
cellophane
alors si vous voulez rêver sur ce livre
vous pouvez prendre une france tout en
rose et moi je trouve que je suis au
contraire de matthieu je trouve que
c'est admirablement écrit par moment pas
toujours par moments il ya de très
belles phrases et les choses mais c'est
presque de la poésie futur hit fait
c'est de l'art abstrait alors vous
pouvez très bien avait sur un tableau
abstrait papa surtout soulagé ça vous
plaise sur une page le clézio chaque
page région chaque phrase chaque idée de
le clézio les tableaux abstraits
vous aimez vous n'aimez pas mon voisin
sont pas du tout d'accord avec votre
analyse précise et que tu partes
américain est tout à fait de figuratif
ouais bon le temps passe très vite sur
le clézio on encore beaucoup de choses à
dire alors on va faire tout même le tour
de la table car bourges acquis et
partager mon enthousiasme le choix pour
le livre mais je pierre bourgeade
l'écrivain et dramaturge joie
aujourd'hui aux critiques littéraires
oui les immortels dites moi j'ai lu dans
le journal que finalement la mise en
scène était retardé la nuit parce qu'on
va le reprendre dans une autre formule
je crois avec jean marie serreau et en
attendant vous êtes en train d'écrire un
scénario d'après la rose rose que vous
avez publié pas longtemps on lit les
journaux
bon revenons à la guerre alors ce livre
je crois que ceux qui en ont parlé ont
bien mis en relief tout le contenu de ce
livre et je crois que c'est intéressant
quand on livre suscite des idées très
opposés parce que ce jeune homme a
montré quel choc n'avait ressenti en
lisant ce bouquin de clézio il ya eu
deux voix contre et j'ai très remarqué
que madame jacques une barre d'elle même
dans sa danse hors prêts exposait
exprimer les idées du monde
contradictoires puisqu'elle est d'abord
c'était du porteur en effet vous arrange
et prennent des photos volées mon frère
ya ya ya c'est une chose nouvelle chez
les romanciers qui dira mes filles se
méfie de l'image le clézio a mis des
photos qui représente assez bien
certaine obsession de son livre et moi
je crois que ça débouche sur un week ou
non tu as raison il c'est vrai les à
triolet la ferai mais je voudrais bien
d'autres je n'aime pas les injurier aux
gens par deux portes tu n'aimes pas la
question
non ça se alors voilà alors ça s'appelle
la guerre aux cons c'est une histoire
très simple c'est une femme qui est dans
une ville et je crois que
la guerre est dans la vie cette femme
s'appelle b à ba c'est un nom qui n'a
pas été pris au hasard c'est un nom très
élémentaire ce sont deux premières
devant la baie et je crois qu'un effet
toutes les femmes et tous les hommes
sont ce personnage du brizio a supprimé
le personnage n'y a pas une personne qui
fit qui a une aventure personnelle c'est
à la fois la bordure d'une personne et
ses aventures de piste les personnes
alors cette semaine dans cette ville est
avec un un ami qui s'appelle monsieur x
qui a une moto et tourne dans cette
ville est alors un effet comme vous
l'avez dit yvan dans les prises unis qui
vont dans les aéroports ils vont dans
l'est sur les sur les autoroutes et au
fur à mesure qu'ils se promènent dans
cette ville ils subissent toutes les
agressions qui se passe dans une ville
et je crois que quand un roman est un
grand roman comme ce livre on peut pas
dire que ce livre copie la réalité mais
c'est la réalité qui se met à ressembler
au roman un des moments les plus
importantes du boucane de plaisir je
crois c'est la description de l'aéroport
ni manque que l'on voit dans un aéroport
on est dans un monde de béton etc là il
peut arriver les pires catastrophes sur
les gens et au moment où vous lisez ce
livre il y avait eu ce ce fait divers
jetés c'est un fait divers c'est à dire
ces gens qui ont été prendre l'avion
dans un aéroport qui se sont retrouvés
le lendemain dans le désert qui trois
jours après se retrouver en ses
patrouilles et puis ils s'en sont sortis
mais il ya eu un certain nombre de jours
pendant lesquels on ne savait pas s'il
allait s'en sortir et je crois qu'ils
sont passés d'une de leurs vies
personnelles avaient leur petite
histoire leur rendez-vous leurs femmes
qui les attend dans un ferr qu'il
s'apprêtait à plonger dans un univers
qu'il n'attendait pas mais qui lui les
attendait et qui était sur le point de
démarrage très bons ils s'en sont sortis
mais il n'aurait pas pu s'en sortir et
dans le cas de crises yuya ça elles
auront retour dans ce bouquin qui son
septième livre mais qui je crois est son
livre le plus fort on retrouve cette
technique qui fait de lui je crois
le romancier peut-être le plus puissant
notre époque c'est à dire que c'est un
type qui à la fois peuvent entrer dans
le détail le plus infime il ya deux
catégories d'écrivains l'appui de celui
qui fait du pointillisme qui décrit le
petit point le petit verre ou
la table de bistrot et puis il ya celui
qui presse les idées et l'occasion il a
tout il peut défendre une ampoule
électrique ou une fourmi ou un rat la
mort d'une mouche et siv en 40 d'alain
effet avant ça devient oui mais j'ai
tout a été fait cher 2002 on discute on
se fout de monsieur l'église ou encore
de ce fou de plus un problème
jamais je veux finir finie à bonal
problème est joué par seconde lorsque
l'eau s'en fout compagne aussi alors
d'une part ils ont des noms ils mendient
presse toute petite chose la bière
produite à ce titre ce naturel nouvelle
quinze jours bonne addition résoudre
comprend rien ne nous intéresse pas je
prénom dominique c'est l'histoire de
l'apocalypse de notre époque
s'il connaît mais dollar semble
appétissant la guerre il a fait la
guerre
je vais vous dire quelque chose de
beaucoup plus grave est beaucoup plus
profond michel faul alors que cette
littérature
aujourd'hui j'ai un très bon argument
contre de biguglia lucien bodard qui est
là l'année dernière la publiant bouquin
formidable sur le massacre des indiens
ouais j'ai retenu la raconter avec la
bonne heure avec monsieur le préfet moi
finir quoi zut alors monsieur godard et
j'étais moi j'ai mes l'occasion aussi de
dire assez
il a raconté comment les arrêts a été
massacrée et le clézio écrira-t-il
fantastique sur le bouquin de bodart et
on s'en fout fait de la littérature sud
allier sur ce qui n'est pas de la ligue
mais laissez moi parler on n'est pas
telle question de l'intérêt de la
quinzaine a expliqué il a expliqué
comment les gens quitter les hammers ce
tueur c'est à dire d'une part du pays
aux crèmes d amiens je vais travailler
la société a rendu compte j ai raconté
brodeur et en plus il ajouté c'était la
tragédie de 60 jours n'est pas celle là
mais que c'est le fait de me mendel a
raconté la pj qui l'a vu n'est ce pas
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on sait plus le
temps à la littérature
nous avons tous des problèmes je dirais
même si vous voulez moi qui suis dit est
ce que je souhaiterais pour le coup
enfin le plus parler de littérature qui
nous emmerdent 11 pas cher monsieur
ça serait peut-être je dirais de publier
les fragments de tous les manuscrits que
nous éditeurs par formation par
tradition nous refusons les pages
droiture et nixon ni expérience de faire
venir un jour ici j'ai remis les gens
que tu enterres refuse et qui comme dans
les lettres d'amour ne pas publier un
petit fragment d'os pas quelques lignes
un peu jaloux de paix qui ne sont pas un
espace comme disait madame barbe les le
cardinal monsieur les urbains florimont
cambrai paris jeudi passé les gens dans
l'échec n'est ce pas aidé à me rahmani
ce que vous êtes vitam aeternam mais
vous ont peur je propose à monsieur
michu voilà un jour de faire une
émission avec des gens comme solutions
justement quelque chose vraiment actif
26 a321 de l'attitude le gpad de la
quinzaine où ou de la roue du futur
opéré avec les yeux aux énormités 10 de
ses yeux n'avait pas vu un physique de
playboy il n'aurait pas eu je ne t'aime
pas
je dois dire a compris que souvient du
moustique cinéma d'alès et non pas qu'il
ait abandonné le cinéma mais il a fait
rentrer cinéma dans le souterrain et je
crois que monsieur truffaut cayla lui
elle quitte le cinéma
oui la littérature cinéma bis spot pour
écrire des pistolets à café au lait
pendant sa soudaine sort et revient
n'est ce pas peut-être aux autres faut
plus avoir aimé servir le truffaut les
tripots critique tout de même souhaité
un poids de mes articles
alors je crois que non seulement celui
de la saison mais ces livres de l'époque
et pas du tout si bien côté prudemment
les chaînes gratuites illizi qui peut
lire aujourd'hui personne n'attend lire
met la vie où je sais bien qu'ils aient
placé celle qu'on va récupérer les
brouilles et pour que cette émission
roule en très très grande partie sur un
humain durable
alors qu'est celui que tu as toi je fais
une demi heure qu'on en parle que c'est
mortel ça commence et d'une façon drôle
vivant quand contre il faut parle d'un
type sur lequel il a fait une prépa sont
multiformes de ses films qu'est ce que
tu veux j'ai couche comme d'art parle
j'écoute bon match peut pas entendre ça
on retrouve tout n'induisent de données
sur littéraire que nolan se passe à
autre chose
or et puis a subi qu'est ce que tu veux
il ne nous reste que quelques minutes et
je crois que jacqueline bard voulait
passer dans un autre livre alors je dis
quand même naguère éponge à des moins
des solutions d'iron man show miam
c'est la joie décide t on alors
jacqueline bard d'ivresse deux minutes
pour nous dire que vous aimez beaucoup
d'autorité aux couleurs story parce que
c'était assez d'un livre charles oui et
moi vous savez je suis une bonne femme
alors je suis pas très intelligente
j'aime pas m'écouter show j'aime tout
comprendre ouais j'aime que les gens
soient sympathiques mais qu'ils soient
jeunes qu'ils soient beaux fut le cas
ouais c'est le cas qu'ils parlent
franchement c'est le gars qui y est et
par vous savez comme j'ai la hantise
d'écrire pour passer dans mes pigeons
donc rien n'oblige
ben j'ai trouvé je trouve que c'est chez
de vote consacre passe et tu as dans la
littérature dans l oms l'apparition d'un
mario gc flammarion et c'est une
histoire d'amour pour les millions de
lecteurs dit d'abord pour noter pas
content on vous tue cochon ça j'apprends
que ça te dit ça fait un mois que je
croyais que c'était une marque de
chaussettes
[Rires]
quelqu'un a lu ce livre isabelle sander
disons d'un jeune homme qui aime une
jeune fille la jeune fille est pauvre le
jeune homme est riche et puis alors le
jeune homme et posa jeune fille la jeune
fille meure
alors tout le monde pleurait alors à
partir de sable on peut faire n'importe
quoi je veux dire que dans l'union
segal et froid quand il taira cure c'est
toutes les portes ouvertes et celle que
dominique de roux l'espère mais qui
reste derrière
bon bien bon jade et moi j y avoir de l
histoire finalement bon je vous laisse
ou été ratissé les abords de questions
hier tim sarnoff nord veut dire que dans
l'amérique de la violence est à session
au non-cumul internet la cgem beaucoup
patricia final j'ai lu sans merci
vous devez évidemment deux était aux
antipodes la porte j'ai pas pu lire le
jeu passe je trouve qu'il ya une parenté
en plus mais aulas vous y penserez vous
dégoûter site vous eu à mon avis je
compte d'abord des parents oui
une parenté avec les premiers à nous de
terminer sauvage
oui la fecris trash sur tout le monde
qui vit en moi parce qu'elle est née
mais je crache pas sur tout le monde je
dis la vérité notre petit jazzy et je ne
voulais surtout pas me aimé nico vous
aime parce qu'il ne voulait pas on ne
voulait surtout pas mais moi je veux
quand même je demande que ça c'est pas
vrai je crois qu'on est mon livre
d'ailleurs heureusement le temps allait
passer plus vite que nous le souhaitions
nous aurions encore beaucoup de choses à
dire et nous avions encore beaucoup de
livres dont nous voulions parler nous en
reparlons la prochaine fois vitaa titre
de policier jean-claude zylberstein
quand même bien celui de josh homme
était résultat la prochaine aulas et
pendez moi oui pour combattre le dirait
un film avec robert mitchum
on allait voir bon eh bien merci jean
claude vercey nous en reparlons plus
longuement c'est une émission en direct
alors bien sûr certains n'ont pas le
temps dira tout ce qu'il voulait dire on
a vraiment une attente de la prochaine
fois tu parles rapport comparant à james
baldwin on parlera de michel tournier
droit des eaux nous parlerons de
résident prochaine jsb louis ne viendra
nous voir dans trois semaines à semaine
prochaine reste banni viendra et on
parlera aussi du livre de guyot ta vie
de philippe sollers et piotr rawicz
alors nous vous donnons rendez vous
mercredi prochain à 22h40 remercié les
invités qui sont venus remercier notre
invité à ses deux premières émissions
nous donnons rendez vous mardi prochain
écrivez nous un post scriptum 116 avenue
du président-kennedy paris 16ème si vous
voulez venir à cette émission est il
maintenant je crois qu'il est
malheureusement temps de se séparer de
vous dire bonsoir et même à cette
heure-ci bonne nuit je crois
[Musique]